welcome everybody it is another day
another white house coronavirus press
briefing this one is scheduled
relatively early it was rescheduled to
6:00 p.m. Eastern Time so starting a
little later and we will join the press
conference with audio and video whenever
it starts now I we have to deal with the
last 24 hours
of accelerated instability and delusions
from the President of the United States
over the last 24 hours we have seen the
president go from I have the ultimate
authority with governors and they will
do what I say too here's a road map but
every governor can do whatever they want
to now going to the governors are the
bad people I am with the protesters and
imagine protesters and we need to
liberate that's Trump's word not mine
we need to liberate some of these states
that I mean liberation implies
enslavement so we're going to get to all
of that but we are extremely rapidly
going in the very very very wrong
direction so I will wait a little bit
for more people to to connect we are
live on Twitter twitch YouTube and
Facebook a little bit touch-and-go there
with twitch I guess there's a problem
right now with restream and twitch we
had a false start but now and now it's
happening so it's it's all very very
exciting
we are back today to a membership goal
we've bolstered the power more power on
the david pakman show website and it
should be well equipped for today I'll
talk about that a little later and in a
moment I'm going to get to to the
rapidly increasing weaponization of
propaganda by the president a few super
chats to mention zesty African says
David Pakman more like David Paku Paku
woo woo kawaii okay panda man says hey
David is it true what they say about
Jewish guy's penis I don't know what
they say I've that's not a conversation
I've ever had with anyone
Matthew Long says please debate Kyle
coolants key on voting for Biden yeah I
don't know I think that that are
we'll divide the left and I'm looking
not to divide the left because removing
Trump is so important
Quincy vagal says David I have friends
who dislike Trump but say they'll vote
third party or sit it out because they
lit this like Biden can you explain why
this only helps Trump yes anybody who
doesn't vote is getting Trump one step
one vote closer to re-election anyone
who votes for third party candidate is
getting Trump one vote closer to
re-election that's a vote Trump doesn't
need to win so I've got a bunch of clips
about that and you know I don't know
that we want to get to something so ugly
today talaga says would you debate Kyle
on modern day debate about Bernie or
bust listen Bernie Sanders isn't even
running anymore so for me the
conversation is really not about Bernie
the conversation is about Trump and
Biden that's really the conversation
right now
the Beckman ATAR blasting in from the
top with a fifty Canadian dollar super
chat says hey David saw your video on
the Senate race and how martha mcsalley
and susan collins are doing terribly i
tried looking at polling info on
mcconnell mcgrath but couldn't find any
do you know more about it I don't think
there is much polling on that when I
looked for polling on Thursday for my
story I didn't see any any recent
polling on that Jeremiah maudlin says
did you see my super chat YouTube
membership patreon membership and
website membership yesterday lol gave
what I thought was a good suggestion
Jeremiah ice ice always try to see
everything I try to thank every member
patron and read every Super chat I it's
I can't imagine I would miss all of them
yesterday but if ITIF I really apologize
my very very much so Donna Williams says
thank you David can't watch without you
Matthias Germany says David do you make
a special diet do you look fit yes it's
a very special diet it's so special I
couldn't even really qualify it or
quantify it Charlie says David which
filling for your burrito carne asada or
carnitas
I don't eat pork so I believe cotton eat
that says pork so for me it's got asada
typically I actually go with grilled
chicken Paula Faust says I intend to
vote for Biden we need to unite
one to vote out Trump we do Randy Wright
says is there any value in voting in the
upcoming primaries yes always we want
turnout up we want engagement high but
you know the safe way to do it is
absentee we really shouldn't be having
any in-person voting at this point in
time and Zachary Foster says ignoring
Trump do you think there's any governors
who have overstepped and are being too
heavy-handed how do we have this
conversation I'm open to the idea that a
governor could overstep but my general
sense now is the problem is not doing
enough rather than doing too much from
from what I've seen Josh go Frannie also
sends a super chat okay let's get into
the disaster of the last 24 hours so
yesterday Trump comes out with these
guidelines for reopening America the
guidelines are not in principle
ridiculous they're not in principle
ridiculous you need 14 days of declining
see the thing is I think you need 14
days of declining active cases the
guidelines are 14 days of declining new
cases which is very different and very
very dangerous opening gyms in phase one
seems like a very dangerous idea but the
concept of you need a full two weeks of
success combined with testing capacity
the concept is okay in practice it was
absolutely and completely ridiculous the
way that it was laid out and of course
the problem now is the states that would
soonest qualify for moving to phase one
are imploding let's take a look at that
we've got data here or data call it
whichever you want heartland hot spots a
sudden rise in coronavirus can we close
this crap oh my god
you got to do something about that
sudden rise in coronavirus cases is
hitting rural states without
stay-at-home Orders and when you look at
which states that is you see that they
are let me see the full list here up
above ok Oklahoma 53% increase in one
week Arkansas up 60% Nebraska up 74%
Iowa up 82%
Dakotah up 205 percent these are the
places that are itching to reopen and
unfortunately when you look at the
numbers these are not numbers that
suggest we should be reopening anytime
soon United States now 700,000 official
cases I'm increasingly of the mindset
that the real number is somewhere
between 5 and 20 times this so I think
we're it's somewhere between 3 3 and 14
million cases would be my guess and when
you look at some of these numbers if you
look at growth in new cases you've got a
lot of places here that the number is
not high but percentage-wise
it's very very concerning when you look
at it your Florida Texas cases are
growing more quickly Ohio had an almost
10% increase today and we've still got
hours to go
Indiana's at 6% in one day but we have
hours to go Virginia is that like 9% we
have many hours left to go North
Carolina plus about 6% today it's not
the end of the day yet Tennessee up 5%
Arizona up 6 7% so if you're growing 6
or 7% a day in 10 days you are a huge
hotspot and we we are going in a very
very dangerous direction I'm desperate
to get out of this as much as anybody
but this doesn't seem like the right
time to do it when you look at the
national numbers again have we peaked or
not I guess but again the difference
between 34,000 new cases and 29,000 new
cases it's a lower growth factor for
sure but this is not a time to be
opening things up what we need is a
decline in active cases and that only
happens when recoveries start to
outnumber new cases and then of course
you can avoid new cases by just avoiding
testing it's harder to avoid deaths and
as you can see here this this April 14th
data is because New York reclassified a
bunch of deaths presumptive Cova deaths
they didn't even have enough tests right
we still don't have enough tests but
they were reclassified as Cova deaths
but forget about that we still had two
days in a row the last two days 2600 and
2100
the highest death days that we are we
are reaching new highs almost every day
still and it is very dangerous to look
at reopening right now now one other
very brief thing to mention there's been
a lot written about the IH Emmy model
and the gist of it is this model is not
really that accurate unfortunately this
is the model that the government is
predominantly depending on it really
doesn't seem like it's that accurate we
did get an update we went four days
without it being updated it was updated
today so the good news is the peak death
day is now presumed to have been April
15th now the problem with that is that
we have this kind of confusing data from
April 14th that's not really being
included here so you know the models are
already classifying deaths differently
but according to this we are past the
peak and now we are supposed to be
declining also the total deaths expected
have gone down by about another thousand
but there are quite increased questions
about the accuracy of this model I I
mention it only to let you know how much
the numbers are changing and if you look
at Massachusetts you will see very
quickly that in four days so four days
ago the Massachusetts model said we were
expecting 8200 deaths now the
Massachusetts model says we are
expecting 3,200 deaths 60 it's a 60 it's
at like a 5/8 that's like 62 percent
reduction in just a four day period okay
it also has changed from saying we were
supposed to peak on April 29 - April 20
so when the model swings so drastically
I think there are a lot of people
rightly questioning whether this is a
model that the government should be
making any sorts of predictions on then
we get to Donald Trump absolutely losing
his mind Donald from earlier today
tweeting liberate Minnesota liberate
Michigan and liberate Virginia and save
your great second-amendment
Donald Trump arguably is weaponizing the
protest against the virus this could
lead to more deaths because of the virus
itself it could lead to people saying
hey Trump says liberate that means go
out and do stuff and maybe Eve
become violent this is incredibly
dangerous this is
he seems to be critically ill I don't
know how else to describe it it seems
like critical illness and these are some
of the folks so we'll get to dr. Phil
these are some of the folks that are out
protesting I can't go between those
houses you can't buy paint you can't
fight a lot you can't pay lawn
fertilizer or grass seed or whatever
come on all statewide really you know
it's time for our seat to be opened up
we're tired of not being able to buy the
things that we need go to the
hairdresser's get our hair done yeah
sorry about that and then we'll get to
that later too now listen to dr. Phil
listen to what dr. Phil said to Laura
Ingraham Laura they never are and thank
you for having me on and thank you for
giving a voice to this because it's so
very important this is invisible I can't
show you an x-ray of depression I can't
show you an x-ray of anxiety but the
fact of the matter is the longer this
lockdown goes on the more vulnerable
people to get and it's like there's a
tipping point there's a point at which
people start having enough problems in
lockdown that it will actually create
more destruction and actually more death
across time then the actual virus will
itself people how many times is he going
to use the word actual 250 people a year
die from poverty and the poverty line is
getting such that more and more people
are going to fall below that because the
economy is crashing around us and
they're doing that because people are
economists dr. Phil they're dying from
the coronavirus I get that but look the
fact of the matter is we have people
dying
we have 45,000 people a year die from
automobile accidents okay so automobile
accidents don't spread via contagion
right important 45,000 people a year are
not dying in accidents because somebody
coughed on them okay cigarettes if you
smoke around someone you can't smoke a
cigarette and give ten people lung
cancer right you can go to work and
cough and give the virus to ten people
this is really this
this is people trust this guy people
trust this guy guys come on sixty
thousand here from swimming pools but we
don't shut the country down for it again
swimming pool related deaths
those aren't viral contagion you can't
say you know what I'm sick of staying
home I'm going to go out and by virtue
of that ten more people might catch a
swimming pool death right
this is weaponized idiocy it is
weaponized ignorant these people are
endangering our country then you we're
not even gonna talk about dr. oz today I
just can't tolerate we're going you know
we're gonna go into the weekend I want
to try to end on a more positive note or
something we're not even gonna talk
about dr. oz today but really really bad
okay let me thank a whole bunch of
people and answer questions as we wait
here for the start of this press
briefing first of all on none other than
twitch turkey bacon and cheese has
gifted 25 subscriptions today putting
him at 250 subscriptions gifted since
the start of our twitch journey thank
you to turkey bacon and cheese I can't
drive 55 Cabo Wabo has subscribed Aniak
and bit 101 have subscribed truck chef
has subscribed and darka ha ha has
subscribed and says Blau quit crashing
hosts ok I don't know what that means
exactly but I rely appreciate the
support
regardless super chats that are coming
in let me see here Amy gray says Trump
being late to press conferences daily is
disrespectful to the press and rude I
would love it if the reporters walked
out when he didn't arrive on time I bet
Trump would go crazy you know the the
thing is the opposite they tend to file
in when they get like the two-minute
warning Dinkins says hey David would
love to do more to help with your show
is there a way to become a moderator
thanks for all you do
beta yes if you want to apply for twitch
or youtube moderator status you have to
contact me through my website contact
form with either a link to your twitch
page if you want to be a twitch mod or a
link to your
YouTube page everybody has one like it's
your Google account YouTube page thing
if you want to be a YouTube moderator
please and thank you
Jeremiah maudlin says you really did
it's ok though my suggestion was you put
a donate button on your website so those
who do not want a monthly recurring fee
assessed have an option to donate
without others taking their cut ok yeah
we can we can look at doing that the
demand for that is lower than you might
think
Joe Paul Cheney says Kirk or Picard I
don't know anything about Star Trek I
don't know anything about it
bolon Newlin says if a if a flat the
curve is the aim then shut down might
lead to a huge spike once things open up
maybe the sensible thing is more like
what Sweden did everything I'm reading
about what Sweden has been doing is not
very positive not very positive
the Beckman ATAR says related to my last
question do you think Amy McGrath has a
chance at Austin Mitch McConnel yeah she
has a chance I mean it's it's tough to
unseat the Senate majority leader
because he has state money and he has
national Republican money but it is
possible and it would be an amazing
thing it would be amazing Sabrina Zafar
how many patrons until your hair gets
bleached also you sound nasally not good
I was just I was just running and after
I run I get a little bit you know these
these things happen to the best of us
but I feel good right now I mean I could
be a symptomatically coming down with
something but I feel good right now BR
says I say we let those who don't want
to listen to the shelter place be let
out but they need to sign a paper that
if they get sick with kovat they won't
be taken to the ER grown kids who don't
listen the problem is it's not just
about them take agreeing not to take up
ER space it's also about the fact that
they spread it to others and so if it
were only the non compliance people that
are at risk it's like okay go and have
at it right sort of a Darwinian type
natural selection but they get other
people sick they get other people sick
and that's that's the real problem okay
let me say thank you to some folks who
have signed up on my membership very
very quickly here Brad Erickson is new
member number one
de Rondo Paulo is new member number two
david mosley made a patreon pledge I'm
gonna count everything today we're
counting everything okay so so that's
number three will count patreon and
membership Hector Castillo is new member
number four natty Roper is new member
number five
Brendan Franklin is new member number
six Craig
stylin is new member number seven
Steffes strauder is number eight Remy
LeBeau has pledged on patreon but we're
counting it as number nine and I very
much appreciate that so as many of you
know the best way to support the daily
streams and the clips and all of that
stuff is just to grab a membership at
join pakman.com all the info is there
the website is on steroids right now so
it really should not crash no matter how
many people try to sign up at once and
if you want a discount you don't have to
take it but the discount makes a
membership two bucks a month it's twenty
twenty now we're down about five hundred
and fifty members since march through
the virus fiasco and it's very
understandable why i totally get that
but if you are in a position where a
couple bucks a month is reasonable for
you we're asking that you sign up at
join pakman.com everybody will be
thanked everybody everybody who signs up
is going to receive an explosive thank
you from me
nasty cues says I turned a friend into a
david pakman fan and now she watches the
streams thanks for all you do I
appreciate that very much and hi to your
friend pear Tirin from Sweden says Trump
can be as late as he wants I have to
pull an all-nighter since I have to go
shopping in five hours to get non
crowded shopping Mayall in chat stay
well and safe that's crazy so if it must
be midnight or one in Sweden
I'm guessing and you're gonna stay up
all night to go shopping first thing
that sounds bad pear I'm worried about
that that's scaring me that's a scary
scary thing Dinkins has upgraded their
YouTube membership Richard but hello
says how confrontational do you think
Trump will get will the media today on a
scale of one to ten ten
Trump's performance Monday I think high
confrontation today I think very very
high confrontation today again if you
look at the the crazy stuff that Trump's
been tweeting liber8 Minnesota liber8
Michigan liber8 Virginia almost now like
it's Trump against the governor's after
saying we're working with the governors
I would expect a very very aggressive
Trump today real quick one other thing I
wanted to show you here's a video of
people saying people Christopher
McDonald and some other people saying
that when Trump tweeted cob feffy
whenever it was 2017 it was a signal
about coronavirus guys kovat cob feffy
right right take a look he was a group
of very intelligent folks that gather
together I believe most of them were
military yes and they work directly with
the president yes and they're
communicating in a code that I could
never even dream of using Kofi fee was
said by the president United States and
his folks that were around him in a
video yeah he first became the president
that folks said well I wonder what that
means what does that mean I don't know
well then it come to find out the Kovan
19 when you break it down is Cove fefe
right so they already were sending a
signal down range to the evil ones right
we know what's going on yeah yeah so I
mean listen guys how do you even fight
that that's overwhelmingly precise and
accurate and I think that that's that's
all it sounds legit to me exactly it
sounds legit to me okay Miz Smith says
you were wonderful in making sense of
the insanity thank you do you think
Trump and company will rob us blind then
Democrats will have to resolve I hope
not I hope I you know there's this idea
that there's people on the Left who want
Trump to do bad things to people and
hurt people so that then someone can
come clean it up and and remove Trump no
I just
it's op Trump needs to be removed period
and that you know the the idea that I
want the stock market to fail or people
to die it's crazy it's literally crazy
black butterfly says what do you think
would happen
the West Coast states decided to secede
from the union during the pandemic I you
know I don't even really want to engage
in that because it's that's just not
going to happen
rat cracker says Ben Shapiro says a
healthcare system can have only two of
the following cost quality or
universality is that true what evidence
proves or disproves that's not true you
can have all of these things it's just
how much are you willing to pay so it's
not this the idea that you can only have
two is not accurate imagine that you
have like a triangle and if you want to
have a lot of two it's go at it I've
actually done segments on this before if
you want high quality and high
universality it's going to be expensive
we just might say it's worth it and
we're gonna pay for it if you want low
cost and high quality it probably can't
be universal if you want Universal and
low cost the quality probably has to be
low so it's wrong it's just a matter of
week we can have it it's just going to
be more expensive than some
right-wingers believe is worth it to
have a high quality universal healthcare
system but no he's wrong that you can't
have it very wrong
unknown prodigy says the virus is too
contagious to ever be safe well we need
a vaccine and treatments by the way
there I don't have anything in front of
me to present to you today but on Monday
on the show I probably will there are
some good signs about Ramdas aveer which
is the Gilead Sciences drug and I you
know we always want to be careful but
I'm seeing some reports that seem okay
one of the studies didn't have a placebo
group and that's a real problem but I'm
interested in seeing what comes of
Ramdas aveer the chloroquine stuff
notice it's been days since Trump
mentioned it days since Trump mentioned
chloroquine a lot of people have
actually died from chloroquine z-pak
combination so that's that's not good
not good at all let me thank a few other
people who have signed up on my website
let me see where I left off
here bro Michael how okay Jared Doherty
is new member number ten today at join
pakman.com Brandon Johnson is new member
number 11 Ben blitz is new member number
12 John Fisher is new member number 13
and Jesse Mannion is new member number
14 today at join pakman.com we are back
to a website membership goal but I just
decided patreon counts we're just it's
it's all counting we're just dropping
everything in from above it's all
counting patreon website memberships
it's all happening today they see people
saying Ramez aveer is as bad as
chloroquine from dez Avira's bad i've
not seen that i've that's again i've no
emotional attachment to any of these
possible treatments but i've not seen
that okay
David Britain says is it me am I
overreacting or did Trump just tell his
supporters in Virginia to take up arms
by tweeting liberate Virginia and Savior
great second Amendment rights it is
under siege yeah
Trump is arguably mobilizing real-world
violence with these three tweets
liberate minnesota liberate michigan
liberate virginia and save your great
Second Amendment I hope that he's asked
about it today my instinct is he'll
probably play coy with it he'll probably
play coy on T picaridin
says hi do you like Mata do you have a
favorite brand you know I don't
Argentinians tend to love Mata it's not
my thing it's really not my thing I'm
more of a coffee and tea guy
Jamal Swift says hey homie thank you
have a good weekend be safe likewise
Jamal's been around the streams for a
while great to hear from you tyka says I
report 45 tweets for inciting violence
yeah I think a lot of people are doing
that but unlikely it will do much Danny
Thompson says Minnesota says in reply
liber8 the White House yeah that that's
really the liberation that needs to
happen what hold on a second where did
that go liber8 there it is rat cracker
says studies show that the u.s. pays
twice what other developed countries
paying health care costs how does
Medicare
all fixed this how does it lower cost
you know it doesn't lower it as much as
it needs to and that this has been my
big problem with the medicare-for-all
proposals which is they assume sometimes
a 50% reduction in the cost of providing
care without actually explaining how we
do it and removing bureaucracy and
negotiating drug prices at the country
level would not save you 50% and that's
something I've been critical of a lot of
the plans for all you need yeah all you
need entertainment says I love your
trigger moments okay I don't know which
ones those are James Nook says did you
see the video of the public and
emergency services clapping on
Westminster Bridge in London makes me
embarrassed to be a Londoner I did not
see that Matias Germany says will you
miss Trump when he's gone someday I
don't think I will in any real sense not
in any real sense rat cracker says a
couple of years ago California and
Vermont tried single-payer conservatives
said it didn't pass because they
couldn't find a way to fund it is that
true I don't know much about the
California situation it is not true that
Vermont simply couldn't find a way to
fund it there were bigger problems and
we've done the post-mortem on what
happened in Vermont and it's more
complicated than that although because
I've not looked at it for a while now
I'd need to refresh to be precise zesty
African says I'd pay you to hit the nené
on camera I don't even know what that
means guys jeez I hope it's not racist
Deirdre yuusha UC says has subscribed at
the soy boy level on YouTube Ben Taylor
says how long should we go on J
journaling and debating before we act we
can't wait until we wake up to be led
into a cattle car do the five generals
ever step in and remove Trump if he
tries to become a dictator listen I the
last week has suggested to me that Trump
won't go peacefully if he loses in
November but that doesn't mean he won't
go I think he will go
he will just say it was rigged it wasn't
fair voted that you know he's not going
to go peacefully in what we would expect
an adult to do but he's going to go he's
going to go no doubt about that let me
say a huge thank you to Madison crass
how crass of you to sign up at join
pakman.com John May banks is new member
number 16 today and because we're
counting patreon today Jessica jingle
Jessica jingle is nooooo not number one
77 number 17 new member and patron
number 17 today very very exciting stuff
today scheduled for 6 p.m. we are about
9 minutes past that and standing by for
Donald Trump nobody else has entered the
room yet usually we see dr. Burks and
dr. foul Chi and whoever the
propagandists of the day are scheduled
to be enter and then Donald Trump enters
but so far nobody hopefully it'll get
going pretty soon thanks to a racer for
the super chat I want to say thanks to
24/7 star for subscribing with twitch
prime mr. potato bug has also subscribed
with prime as has hugs
80 hugs 80 has subscribed with prime
maths maths says greetings from Germany
keep safe man likewise and greetings to
you rat cracker says what are your
thoughts on the idea that we should
lower taxes on middle class people
because they know how to spend it better
than the government does I disagree with
the premise the reason to lower taxes on
the middle class would be that their
marginal propensity to consume is higher
than that of the rich and that's an
economic concept that is probably for
another day locusts says bring back
firefly I watched the first season of
Firefly it's a it's a was a not a bad
show not my favorite you know what was
released I believe it was yesterday foul
de season three foul de is one of my
absolute favorite programs it is now on
Netflix it's subtitled the show is like
half Arabic half Hebrew and it's
subtitled to English tremendous program
absolutely one of the best produced
programs and season three was just
released yesterday and I will likely be
watching any number any number of
episodes this weekend how quickly will
Trump mention Cuomo today I don't know
if he will mention him but he will
certainly be asked about him
Cathy Rodriguez says hi from Miami so
happy I came across your page on YouTube
thank you Eric Lamont says thoughts on
Trump tweeting liber8 states you know
we've talked about that two or three
times today already so for the people
that have been here from the beginning I
don't want to go overboard with that but
it does seem dangerous to public health
and personal safety absolutely if you're
watching on YouTube please remember to
hit that like button and the subscribe
button these things are free completely
free there's almost nothing there's no
such thing as a free lunch we are told
and yet there is no cost real or even an
opportunity cost to hitting like and
hitting subscribe you lose nothing and
we gain a lot a lot to thank Donald
Trump so remember to do that
Ryan Olding says thanks for your honest
and transparent coverage thank you Sarah
Holly and Kelvin Baez have grabbed
YouTube memberships as has Nathaniel
bridges Sarah Holly says Inslee tweeted
strongly against Trump today oh let's
see jay Inslee twitter oh my my keyboard
is running out of battery this is not
this is embarrassing guys I might have
to pull over I have a wired and a
wireless keyboard here I might have to
pull over the wired it could get very
very ugly here okay so that's pinned
that's not today well flit sir my full
statement oh okay I encourage political
leaders to speak out firmly against the
president's calls for rebellion
Americans need to work together to
protect each other that's what's working
in Washington and it's the only way to
slow the spread of
this virus and get us on the road to
recovery oh that's tweet number seven ah
the president statements this morning
encourage illegal and dangerous acts he
is putting millions of people in danger
of contracting kovat 19 his unhinged
rantings and calls for people to
liberate states could also lead to
violence we've seen it before couldn't
say it better myself extremely dangerous
extremely dangerous and glad that
governors are speaking out let me say
thank you to a user who goes by the name
of a black woman for subscribing with
twitch prime also want to say thanks to
blitz lynnster for gifting ten
subscriptions today on twitch which is a
beautiful active community I love it
very very much love it
also thanks to Phil Mogg 'add who is new
member number 18
today on my website join pakman.com and
dave britain who is new member number 19
today at join pakman.com thanks so much
really appreciate the engagement and the
support it's really great to be able to
meet with everybody at sort of this time
most weekdays and hear how everybody's
doing and the support has been really
great
mit UCLA is a dirty word in Arun D
Burundi says what do you think of people
who may want to move out of the country
if Trump gets reelected I think very few
of them will really do it you know we
see that with many election cycles and
you know I host people are going to stay
in the country that they call home
period so I get the I get the feeling of
it but very few people actually do it
constitutional peasant says right-wing
YouTube folks go on each other's shows
quite a bit and share fans
is this something we on the Left need to
emulate I'd love to see you on majority
report destiny noemi's show and others
yeah yeah I mean you know the here's the
thing the reason I don't tend to invite
other hosts on my show very often is the
interviews don't do well people on my
people in my audience tend not to be
that interested in seeing me talk to
other people they can just also watch on
youtube who do the same thing
the the the segments don't do well which
is why I tend not to do them quite
frankly you're a monofin says bingo
bandana as a new element to your David
Pakman show
whoops where'd that go uh-oh where did
that go new David Pakman show
merchandise yeah we could look at a
bandana we could look at something like
that tiny house builder says how did you
like Cuomo's response to trump today
yeah it was great I mean if people
didn't see it the part I saw Andrew
Cuomo said I don't need Trump to give me
the constitutional rights that have been
around since before he was born and it
was accurate precise and well said
thanks to Mitch Dominguez for signing up
on YouTube zesty African says can
progressives ever gain leverage if we
vote blue no matter who every time also
peepee poo-poo listen I don't know about
vote blue no matter who cuz I don't do
it okay so for me there's no vote blue
no matter who for me its we are now at a
point on April 17 2020 where either
Donald Trump gets four more years or Joe
Biden becomes president so I'm choosing
Joe Biden over Donald Trump
there's nothing about vote blue no
matter who I'm not a Democrat I don't
particularly care about the Democratic
Party and I'm not enamored with it in
any way so it is not for me vote blue no
matter who Conor Brenner says it's been
a rough week thanks for keeping on
Edward Joe says thanks for everything my
mom and I are big fans thank you I
appreciate that Edward info minimal says
orange Cassidy should stand with pouchy
during this Hector murk says you make
the hearings worth it
thanks Hector Martha Gaytan says dr.
drew dr. oz dr. Phil need to stay in
their Lane yes yes we played a clip
earlier already of dr. Phil talking
about we don't quarantine for
swimming-pool deaths or cigarette deaths
and of course you can't spread those by
coughing on coworkers and it's insane
insane and in fact the irresponsibility
of dr. Phil and dr. oz now doctor
drew early did say some whacked-out
stuff but he has apologized now as the
last I saw dr. Drew apologized people
can tell me in the chat I will stand
corrected if dr. drew after his apology
went back to saying crazy stuff then let
me know and I will you know take that
back very very strongly but as far as I
knew dr. Drew had apologized for his
embarrassing Mis statements about the
virus rat cracker says will you debate
Kyle kolinsky on voting for Biden again
I'm not looking to divide the left and I
think that such a debate would could
only serve to divide the left in the net
so I want to avoid that Boland Newlin
says thoughts on half of Iceland having
kovat without knowing it no symptoms no
nothing good news or bad so I don't know
that is that I I think that there was a
sample done and it was a self-selected
sample that showed 50 percent antibodies
but that does not if that's the study
you're referring to that does not mean
that half of the country had it that
being said it's not inconceivable but if
you're referring to the same study I saw
it is not actually evidence of that Ron
says with all the anti China rhetoric
from Trump and the right wing are we on
the verge of a conflict with China quite
possibly I was actually reading a lot
about that yesterday I am NOT a China
expert or a China expert but I'm reading
more and more more about it because it
does now when we say a conflict we're
not talking about like a ground war or
anything like that I think it's
important to point that out but conflict
can mean a lot of different things let
me say thanks to tea Tremper for signing
up at the soy boy level dr. Rehn sends a
super chat college movie geek has signed
up on YouTube a she'd Everton says hey
love the show thanks a she'd Paul
mcbrady has subscribed on YouTube
Shannon Dennis says Ingraham has become
a true villain it's worrisome yeah you
know the thing for me about the whole
dr. Phil on on Laura's show is she's a
well-educated woman there's no way in
hell that she believes this crap there's
also a clip there was a clip of her I'm
not gonna play it now cuz it looks like
we're close to starting but there's a
clip of her interviewing pouchy
where she said hey we didn't shut down
over SARS or HIV why do we have to shut
down over coronavirus I don't think
she's that stupid I think she's just you
know propagandizing and doing what Fox
News has decided is gonna be there Lane
she couldn't possibly be that stupid I
think I think Matt Melendez says that
super chat users name was pronounced
Locutus of Borg
it's another Star Trek reference keep up
the good work yeah I'm not a big Star
Trek guy Romeo says here you go go buy
some batteries yeah I've got this
wireless keyboard because most of the
elements of my setup are kind of far
away and I think it's just I think it's
just dying I also have a wireless mouse
and I just replaced the batteries on
this a few days ago it's possible that
they have a similar battery life here's
doctor foul Qi dr. Burks dr. Redfield
coming in I believe that that sonny
perdue the agriculture secretary admiral
Jarrar is their prop for-profit health
care propagandist Seema Verma is there
and Donald Trump not far behind let me
get a few other thank-yous in Hugh Jass
ooh I I know that one I watch Howard
Stern is new new member number 20 today
Christine Kohli is new member number 21
linda stranger is number 22 and I think
that catches me up thank you very much
join pakman.com is the place to sign up
I will switch to the c-span feed after a
minute or two because I like the audio
level on it it's cleaner and they show
the reporters when the reporters ask
questions so don't don't you know panic
when I do that everything's gonna be
just fine but the c-span feed often
takes a few minutes to start which is
why we'll start with this completely
toxic fox news feed but then I will be
switched switching over and it's going
to be very very exciting is this is this
the Agriculture Secretary sonny perdue
right now I'm unsure if it is if he's
there it's clearly gonna be about some
propaganda related to the food supply
but I actually
I'm doubting if that's sonny perdue
thanks to Jake our who is new member
number 23 here is Trump let's see what
happens today expect insanity thank you
very much I just had a great
conversation with the leading faith
leaders of our country at that idea
extremely well we learned a lot I
learned a lot and all right let's just
make the switch now so we'll be we'll be
live over here on c-span from the get-go
the audio feed is better we've got
better angles and I just think it'll be
a better experience for all of us thank
you thank you very much I just had a
great conversation with the leading
faith leaders of our country it went
extremely well we learned a lot I
learned a lot and about what you know
some things that are very interesting
they're very positive I thank them all
for being on the call and yesterday we
unveiled detailed guidelines for
America's governor's to initiate a phase
safe and gradual reopening of America
that's what's happening the guidelines
provide governor's with the fact driven
and science-based metrics they will need
to make the decisions that are right for
their own particular state to view the
guidelines you can go to the website at
white house.gov slash opening America so
that's white house.gov slash opening
America Treasury has sent out economic
relief payments to more than 80 million
Americans who have their direct deposit
information on file with the IRS and an
incredible success it has been if you
have not received your check please
visit irs.gov get my payment how about
that one IRS gov get my payment how
about that that way the IRS can get you
your payment in days and they've done a
fantastic job I have to say and you
won't have to wait for a check in the
mail I have some very good
we sent out 80 million deposits and less
than 1% had even little problems a
couple had minor glitches but it
substantially less than 1% so out of 80
million deposits less than 1% and that
gets corrected immediately so just
please do as they say you'll get that
very quickly very easily today I'm also
announcing that secretary Purdue who
happens to be right next to me handsome
man and the Department of Agriculture
will be implementing a 19 billion dollar
relief program for our great farmers and
ranchers as they cope with the fallout
of the global pandemic very honored to
be doing this our farmers ranchers we
have these are great people great
Americans never complain never complain
they just do what they have to do the
program will include direct payments to
farmers as well as mass purchases of
dairy meat and agricultural produce to
get that food to the people in need the
USDA will receive another 14 billion
dollars in July that will have funding
to continue help are helping and this
will help our farmers and our ranches
and it's just money well deserved weird
so not only were they targeted at one
point by China and that was over a
period of time and you saw that
happening and they never complained but
that worked out very well 12 billion
dollars they got and 16 billion dollars
they got and now it's 19 billion and I'm
just gonna ask secretary Purdue to
explain exactly how we're going to
handle it thank you oh boy
mr. president you may remember earlier
this year you tweeted a message to our
farmers and ranchers that no matter
their circumstances you pledged to stand
behind them and while none of us could
ever have anticipated this type of
pandemic that we're currently in
I think today's announcement is proof
that you put our you have our farmers
backs and that you will continue to do
this except the Obama administration
when they tried to train train Trump's
administration on the PlayBook I think
America now knows that more than ever
the wholesome foods that our families
depend upon and starts with America's
farmers and ranchers America agriculture
has been hard-hit like most of America
with the coronavirus and President Trump
is standing with our farmers and all
Americans to make sure we all get
through this national emergency so today
thanks to your direction and leadership
mr. president USDA is announcing the
coronavirus food assistance program as
you mentioned this new 19 billion dollar
program will take several immediate
actions to assist farmers ranchers and
consumers in response to the Cova 19
national emergency the program is really
divided into two parts one is a direct
payment 16 billion dollars in direct
payments to farmers ranchers and
producers who've experienced
unprecedented losses during this
pandemic since we wanted to get the
payments out to producers as quickly as
possible we decided to use the funds and
the CCC the current funds of six and a
half million billion dollars combined
with the 19.5 of covert money rather
than wait for the replenishment of the
CCC funds in July based on industry
estimates of damage mr. president it is
becoming apparent that we'll need the
additional CCC funds as we continue to
track the economic losses secondly and
this is really important as well the
USDA will be purchasing three billion
dollars in fresh produce dairy and meat
products to be distributed to Americans
in need
Food Bank networks as well as other
community and faith-based organizations
having to dump milk or plow under
vegetables ready to market is not only
financial just how they cut food stamps
when there's no pandemic and then
they're like aw let's just start sending
people food this program will not only
provide direct financial relief to our
farmers and ranchers mr. president will
allow for the purchase and distribution
of our agricultural abundance in this
country to help our fellow Americans in
need now in recent weeks we've seen all
of us have seen the heroic patriotism of
our food supply chain workers and
they've shown day in and day out doing
the work will serve so fellow Americans
our farmers have been in the fields
planning and doing what they do every
spring to feed the American people even
with the pandemic as we speak I want to
thank you mr. president for your
unwavering support they want to thank
you for your unwavering support for
America's farmers and ranchers and I
want to commit to you mr. president and
to the American people the USDA will do
everything in our power to implement
this program as quickly and as
efficiently as possible to help our
farmers ranchers producers and consumers
during this great time of need so thank
you very much for having me here today
right god bless you god Bless America
god bless america a beautiful statement
so our great Secretary of Agriculture
was the governor of Georgia for eight
years and the only reason he isn't still
there frankly is that he was term
limited and I said let's get him for
agriculture you've done a fantastic job
we want to thank you very much eight
years at Georgia Wow we really
appreciate it scary up even as we
prepare to rebuild our economy America
continues to wage all-out medical war to
defeat the invisible enemy scourge to
date we have conducted more than three
point seven eight million coronavirus
tests remember six weeks ago we were
gonna be testing millions a week we're
at three point seven million total total
total Izzie Anna we've also tested more
people per capita than South Korea
Singapore in every other country the
United States has the
most robust advanced an accurate testing
system anywhere in the world as of
yesterday we have distributed nearly six
hundred and sixty thousand Abbot IDs now
that's a an incredible tests called the
ID now point-of-care diagnostic test and
it's fantastic
it's uh it's the hot one problem with
this business is it's a hot one till
about two days from now because we do
have a saliva test that just came out
and that can be self administered and
it's said to be fantastic exciting new
quarter thing laboratories they have
been incredible I want to thank Roche
they've likewise been incredible over
the last several days we've seen a
dramatic increase in the number of tests
conducted by hospitals and academic
institutions which have now performed
nearly six hundred thousand tests
there's a tremendous amount of unused
capacity and the states available for
governor's to tap we have tremendous
unused capability within those
laboratories and I hope the governor's
are going to be able to use them the
governor's are responsible for testing
and I hope they're going to be able to
use this tremendous amount of the
governor's are responsible for testing
is a new way that he's been shirking any
responsibilities no tests per week when
you think of that in the next few weeks
we'll be sending out 5.5 million testing
swabs to the state
swabs can be done easily by the
governor's themselves mostly it's cotton
it's not a big deal you can get cotton
easily but if they can't get it we will
take care of it
yesterday the FDA announced a new
collaboration with United Health Group
the Gates Foundation quanta j'en and
u.s. cotton to greatly expand the supply
of essential swabs including a new
polyester q-tip type swab for the corona
virus testing all of these actions will
help our testing capability continue to
grow dramatically so we're helping
people even with swabs we get
ventilators where now the
the king of ventilators we have hundreds
of thousands under construction and you
know need them ourselves the governor's
are in great shape if we do we have a
great stockpile that will immediately
send to the state in need but we've
handled that situation incredibly well I
hope people understand it I wish the
media would get the word out what we've
done in ventilators is amazing because
they're they're big expensive and highly
complex right well speaking to other
countries I spoke to President of Mexico
today great gentleman and I told him
that we are going to be helping him out
with ventilators Heppell helping Mexico
out and we'll be helping some other
countries too we have a lot of very high
level high quality ventilators and none
of those here and there also being
manufactured as we speak
following the announcement of our
reopening guidelines there have been
some very partisan voices in the media
and you recall it takes who have spread
false and misleading information about
our testing capacities nobody thought
overstating demonstrating a complete
failure to understand the enormous scope
of the testing capabilities that we've
brought online and we started really
from Ground Zero we started from really
being very very outdated and obsolete I
really want to make sure everybody
remembers six weeks ago they started
saying stuff like by the end of this
week we'll be testing 1/2 million people
a week the total number of tests done is
3 million total this entire time would
love to see a question about that
the states they use that capability the
states have local points where they can
go a governor can call the mayors and
the mayors can call representatives and
everybody everything is perfect and
that's the way it should work and always
should work will help New York and all
of the other states get even better on
their testing we have to get even better
and some people think a little bit
differently there are areas where you
have vast amounts of area where you have
very few people and almost no people are
infected
and those places will be looked upon
differently by different governor's
concept I think I could have a lot of
news coming out about that over the next
few days I think certain states are
going to come online and they're gonna
start the early stages of the puzzle
that we're putting together and it's
going to be together sooner rather than
later a lot of really incredible things
are happening and at some point in the
not-too-distant future we're gonna have
our country back and it's gonna be I
think really with what we're doing on
stimulus and helping people keep their
businesses together and their lives
together and their jobs it's gonna be
better than ever before everything's
great though I really do
why have you gonna work the current
conversation is reminiscent of what
happened on ventilators you remember
that when requests were made far beyond
what was objectively needed we were
hearing from a certain state and we were
hearing from a lot that they needed far
more ventilators in one case they wanted
40,000 ventilators 40,000 it turned out
that they had plenty and they had a
number of about seven or eight thousand
and that was plenty we supplied them
with a lot but that was the right number
we we got it just about right and if
they did need more we're ready to give
more but I think the surgeons copy over
and there are a lot of governor's just
doing a great job and they're working
with us but we're all working together
the research and development that we've
done at the federal level has been
absolutely incredible the media will be
accepting of these figures when they get
to see the end result I think they're
going to see it and I think they were
already seeing it that includes not only
ventilators but beds we built in most
cases far more than they even needed but
we wanted to err on the side of caution
this is what the governor's wanted they
wanted a certain amount in Louisiana I
spoke with the governor had a long talk
with him and I said you think you'll
need that final Hospital and they
actually didn't need it we've built a
lot of a lot of beds so I appreciate it
from the Gov
and we saved building a hospital in New
York we do static tacular job at the
Javits Center Paris even sending the
ship up because when that happens we
brought it into Co vid but they didn't
they didn't really need it it didn't get
much use but it was there and ready it
wasn't supposed to be used for that
purpose we changed it into that purpose
and it wasn't they are ready willing and
able
same with Javits but they didn't quite
need the rooms that we the beds that we
we produced so we produced almost two
thousand nine hundred beds and I think
I'd rather tell you that we were over
prepared that we were than we were
underprepared and that was a good-faith
effort by New York I have to say that a
very good faith effort but it's nice
that we didn't need that instead of
needing and it was not very occupied but
it was ready to go still there should
something happen but I think they have
it under very good control as you'll
hear from our experts today we've
already built sufficient testing
capacity nationwide for states to begin
their reopening 'he's totally wrong we
really need to be testing somewhere
between one and twenty two million a day
we're doing 130,000 most excitingly in
the coming weeks I think you're going to
see some very very dramatic steps taken
and very safely we're putting safety
first we may be opening but we're
putting safety first and when you look
at the the numbers when you look at the
possible number of death deaths at 2.2
million people and it could have very
well been that it could have been more
frankly I've been looking at numbers
where it could have been higher than
that so it's not true 2.2 million would
be if you literally do nothing and let
it spread through the population no
president could ever reasonably do that
it's an insane thing to compare two
people a minimum if we did nothing would
have been 1.6 if you cut that in half
you're talking about 800,000 900,000
yeah it's like someone who killed 10
people saying listen I could have gone
out and killed a thousand people I
didn't do that and so I need credit for
only kill
1% of the people I could have killed
that's essentially what Trump is saying
here successful they had between a
hundred thousand and two hundred and
twenty thousand to two hundred and forty
thousand on the upside and I think will
be substantially hopefully below the
hundred number and I think right now
we're heading it probably around sixty
maybe sixty five thousand and one is too
many I always say it one is too many is
a horrible thing that happened to our
country there's a horrible thing that
happened to one hundred and eighty four
countries all over the world is a
horrible thing and there was no reason
for it and should never ever happen
again in a few minutes you'll be hearing
from dr. Redfield dr. foul Chi dr. Burks
and admah guar you explained these facts
in in really great detail earlier this
week the FDA authorized two new antibody
test which is a very exciting that will
determine if someone has been previously
infected with the virus bringing the
total to four authorized antibody tests
already this will help us assess the
number of cases that have been
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic and
support our efforts to get Americans
back to work by showing us who might
have developed the wonderful beautiful
immunity beautiful ultimate victory in
this war will be made possible by
America's scientific brilliance there is
nothing like us there is nobody like us
not even close in more ways than one I
wish I could tell you stories what other
countries even powerful countries say to
me the leaders they say it quietly and
they say it off the record but they have
great respect for what we can do and our
country is at a point few weeks ago
think of it four or five weeks ago we
were at a level that nobody had ever
attained the best job numbers we've ever
had the best economy we've ever had
every company virtually was doing better
business than ever before the stock
market was at all-time highs and then
one day they said you got to close it up
and we did the right thing
we saved maybe
millions of lives by doing it the way we
did it but we're paying a price but that
price is very unimportant compared to
the number of lives we're talking about
the NIH and others are conducting
clinical trials of 35 different
therapies and treatments therapies being
so exciting to me because that's really
like if something happens you're gonna
get better
reasonably quickly and without such a
horrible deal as some people have to go
through to that end today NIH announced
that it is launching a public-private
partnership with more than a dozen by
huni pharmaceutical company much they're
made their HHS FDA CDC and the European
Medicines Agency they're all working
together we're working together with a
lot of other countries the partnership
will marshal and coordinate the vast
resources knowledge assets and
authorities of more than a dozen
organizations and agencies to accelerate
development of the most promising
therapies and vaccines the vaccines are
coming along really really well Johnson
& Johnson is very well advanced one
thing is they have to having great great
success but we have to test them and it
takes a long period of time it takes
probably over a year unfortunately but
therapies likewise are coming along very
very well therapy's our immediate when
we get that new dimension hydroxy today
we're also equipping our medical motors
on the frontlines in total we have the
project air bridge and the air bridge
has been incredible the National
strategic stockpile and every other
channel the federal government is
deployed if you think about this forty
four point five million n95 masks nearly
five hundred and twenty four million
gloves sixty three point five million
surgical masks and more than 10 million
gowns and we have 500 million masks
coming in very soon between
manufacturing and orders 500 million
masks the last few months have been
among the most challenging times in the
history of our nation yeah he really
sounds visible enemy is tough and it's
smart and it's vicious
genius German but every day we're
getting closer to the future that we all
have been waiting for I talk about the
light at the end of the tunnel we are
getting very very close to seeing that
light shine very brightly at the end of
that tunnel and it's happening and I
want to thank everybody in the room
I want to thank I actually want to thank
some of the media we've had some fair
coverage Simone appreciated what I'm
going to do is I'm going to introduce a
great vice president Mike Pence and he's
gonna take over a little while I'm gonna
leave and I'm coming right back and
we'll take some questions they're gonna
go over our tremendous testing gonna
leave it I'm coming right back and again
I'll be right back thank you thank you
very much what the hell by the way when
pence talks about that air bridge I just
want a gag Thank You mr. president
good afternoon today as the president
just reflected it remains a challenging
time in the life of our nation because
of the extraordinary efforts of the
American people because of the strong
partnership the federal government has
forged with States across the country
we're making progress America despite
the the treasure didn't weird that Trump
just said I'll be right back and just
left like it's very very weird
listen I've sort of previously committed
to muting pence so I I'm gonna thank
some of my supporters who I like way
better these numbers have already
reflected right up there but Omar
Stiegler has grabbed a membership Kelvin
by as Jennifer Beaupre Rachel Arrington
thank you so much Rachel Jake our
Christine Kohli and just really great
people and Daniel Rivera wonders if
Trump left to reload on sudafed and we
don't have evidence of that we really
don't know other suggesting that it's a
bathroom break a retro path a quants to
know about
Joe Biden and Justin Bieber sharing the
same initials and having huge fan bases
you know I didn't that is that is
suspicious in a way it is strange how
similar both of both of those things are
yeah I didn't I didn't really consider
that Joe Millionaire also suggesting
that it's at or all-time a lot of people
seem to think that these when Trump says
I'll be right back that it is
drug-related and I don't know that we
have any evidence of that per se but
it's people are looking at that very
very strongly okay let's see if pence is
now talking about the air bridge and
masks on duty 5500 active duty military
personnel had been deployed to nine
states including 716 medical
professionals doctors and nurses who
deployed out 14 different hospitals
today among those were 10 hospitals in
New York City and military personnel
were also serving today in hospitals in
Connecticut Texas Louisiana and New
Jersey yesterday as the president
reflected we unveiled the president's
guidelines for opening up America again
there were two parts at the beginning of
those guidelines first the criteria it's
absolutely genuinely shocking how
worthless pens pencils presentations are
he communicates nothing newsworthy he
just praises Trump and it's like
everybody has to play the game the
reporters have to sit there just staring
at pens nobody ever has any questions
for pence unless they're under duress
right you've got to be essentially held
hostage and forced to ask pence a
question to want to ask him something
it's of no value it is of note the
presentation from pence is of no value
its everyday flights are happening
flights are scheduled that's the other
one when he brags that air bridge
flights have been scheduled oh okay I
mean is it is it relevant that there's a
flight landing in 17 days with some
number of masks that we'll never really
know if it awry right I mean do I hope
people understand what we're talking
about here and you know okay I think
people get it I mean people are bailing
the rate
hence literally Pence's ratings are
disaster people are flying out of the
stream right now because pence won't
stop talking about you know this
completely bogus stuff to our most
vulnerable populations as the president
has made clear governors will decide the
time and manner that their states reopen
and we will look to support them in that
effort but as we assured the American
people yesterday the president's
direction our administration will
continue to work with governors across
the country to ensure that they have the
equipment and the supplies and the
testing resources to reopen safely and
responsibly on the subject of supplies
today we had a letter to our nation's
governor summarizing all the medical
equipment and supplies that have been
distributed to their state from FEMA
between the first of this month and
April 14 through project air bridge
through the commercial supply network
we'll be speaking with our nation's
governor's on Monday and detailing that
information at that time as of April
16th as the president reflected briefly
FEMA has coordinated the delivery of
millions of pieces of medical equipment
including 44 million n95 respirators 63
million surgical masks more than 10,000
ventilators and of course deployed more
than 8,600 federal federal medical
states attic beds on the subject of
testing resources we're going to take
some time to speak about our
administration's approach in partnership
with States to continue to expand
testing across the country at this
briefing but from the very outset of
this epidemic a president Trump made
efforts to essentially reinvent testing
in America a traditional testing in this
country that takes place at CDC or at
state labs was designed for basically
the kind of diagnostic testing that is
routinely required but the president
early on in this effort brought together
the leading commercial labs in America
we forged a public and private
partnership there's truly nothing worse
than this there's really nothing worse
than this
imagine that pence went at the end like
imagine
Trump spoke doctor spoke questions then
pence nobody stays right because there's
nothing what are you I want to hear from
doctor foul treat dr. Brooks here and
they put this in the middle about how
great Trump is and how he's scheduled a
flight direction of dr. deborah birx
that is working around the clock to
identify additional testing capacity
across the country we believe that
states could actually more than double
the amount of daily testing that is
happening today by simply activating all
of the labs and dr. Burks will detail
some of those resources today and we'll
be going over those very specifically
with letters out on Monday we've also
been promoting the development of new
and innovative tests we all know about
the 15-minute avid test but the FDA is
currently working on an antibody test
that literally could add 20 million new
tests to our supply even before the end
of April I want to assure the American
people that we're going to continue to
work with your governors and with your
state health officials to scale testing
in the days ahead but as you'll hear
from all of our experts tonight our best
scientists and health experts assess
that states today have enough tests to
implement the criteria of phase one if
they choose to do so
that is a lot we say that again lie
again the given the given the guidance
in the the president's new guidelines
for opening up America again yeah
tell the states that meet the criteria
for going into phase one and then are
preparing the testing that is
contemplated by going to phase one this
is a lot best scientists and health
experts assess that today we have a
sufficient amount of testing to meet the
requirements of a phase one that is not
true
governor's should choose to do that and
you'll hear more detail on that in just
a moment yeah at the president's
direction we're going to be presenting
an outline of our approach to testing in
partnership with States during this
briefing our approach will continue to
be locally act by the way just so
everybody knows in partnership with
States Trump tweeting governors need to
start test
more they are slowly offloading all
responsibility on testing to governor's
despite the fact that it's the federal
government and the FDA and the CDC that
is licensing tests that is responsible
for approving tests right that is so but
it doesn't matter they need now to be
able to say if a if a state doesn't have
enough tests it's the state's fault and
the state's fault alone two very readily
and Admiral Gerar of the US Public
Health Service will summarize our
approach but I want to assure the
American people that at the president's
Direction we are going to continue to
work every single day to make sure that
our states and communities have the
testing they need to reopen at the time
and manner of their choose oh it's not
there and we're gonna make sure all
states have resources and the supply is
crystal clear can reopen their states
and reopen America in a safe and
responsible way with that doctor foul
chief we learned zero from that other
than that he lied thank you very much
mr. vice president so as the vice
president said I'm going to give you a
brief introduction to kind of answer the
question that we've been asked a lot in
fact we had a very productive
teleconference with the Senate
Democratic caucus just a few hours ago
and they asked a number of questions
which were really reasonable questions
questions that are on the mind of a lot
of different people and one of them was
the question that was just posed a
moment ago is are there enough tests to
allow us to be able to go through this
first phase in a way that is protective
of the health and the safety of the
American people so I just want to spend
a couple of minutes clarifying a few
things and maybe providing some
information on a broad 40,000 foot which
you'll hear some of the more granular
details from my colleagues who will be
following me dr. Brooks I think they
asked me to give the 40,000 foot one
because I'm not a testing person I
didn't
testing lab but I'm part of a team that
is looking at this of how we can best
make sure this happens in the right way
so first of all let me say something
that we said before and I apologize if
I'm repeating things that you already
know but I think in some respects it's
important to do that so that people have
clarity and what we're talking about
there are two general types of tests
even though within each general type
there are different subgroups one of
them is to actually test for the
infection is a person infected yeah the
other and I'll get back to that in it in
a second the other is to test as we just
mentioned if someone has been infected
usually someone has been infected who
has recovered and as I'll get to in a
moment that you could assume although we
need to do some more work on that that
that person is actually protected
against subsequent exposure and often
about reality with an identical organism
so what are some of the pluses and
minuses of each because the pluses and
minuses are really going to impact how
we best use the test and how the test
actually should be used so let's take
the test for whether or not you're
infected the test of whether or not
you're infected is a test that right now
is a call to nucleic acid test it's not
an easy test to do there are some that
are more rapid there are some that have
a high throughput they're different
groups within that the good news about
that is that it's a sensitive and
specific test so that if you're infected
you know you're infected so that as I'll
get to in a moment if you need to do
something with that get that person put
them in care take care of them get them
out of circulation that's important the
part about that that I think is often
misunderstood is that if you get a test
today like I did today it's negative if
you get a test today that does not mean
that tomorrow or the next day or the
next day or the next day as you get
exposed perhaps from
someone who may not even know they're
infected that that means that I'm
negative which means if you take that to
its extreme in order to be really sure
you would almost have to test somebody
either every day or every other day or
every week oh right what it is to be
absolutely certain one road map says
test everyone on a rolling to week basis
now the problem that that I I talked
about we're not when I try and compare
this to other situations with what
testing means to you I'm as think most
people know have been involved in
hiv/aids for 38 years 39 years from the
very first week of HIV so that's what I
do if you get a test for HIV and you are
negative and you do not practice any
risk behaviors you can be guaranteed
that next month six months one year from
now you will be negative if you don't
have a risk behavior so there's a big
difference there about what testing
actually means so the point I think
you're getting is that although there is
clearly a place for needing to test
somebody for a given reason a test means
you're negative now now the other test
is an antibody test a test that tells
you in fact that you've been infected
that's really good you're gonna hear
about that a bit about that from my
colleagues in a moment because that will
give you a broader view of two things
one what the penetrance of the infection
had been and number two you can make an
assumption though we still need to prove
that i mean i we are assuming that if
you're infected and you have a anybody
you're protected i don't think that's a
reasonable assumption based on our
experience with other viruses but what
we want to make sure that we know and
these are some of the challenges what is
the titer
that is protective how long is the
protection is it one month is it three
months is it six months it's a year so
we need to be humble and modest that we
don't know everything about it but it
really is an important test
the other thing is the difference
between testing and monitoring out there
what's out there the difference between
what we really needed for for phase 1 is
to be able to identify isolate contact
trace a very important part of when
you're putting pulling back gradually
and slowly on the mitigation and you
have people who might be infected you
want to know they're infected you want
to put them in care that is something
that we absolutely need to do but there
are other ways we I want to make sure
people understand that not to
underestimate the importance of testing
testing is a part an important part of a
multi-faceted way that we are going to
control and ultimately end this outbreak
so please don't anyone interpreted that
I'm down peasant testing but the
emphasis that we've been hearing is
essentially testing is everything and it
is do need to here is the number of
tests we need to be able to do be doing
a day which he hasn't said all of that
now just a couple of things before I
hand it over to my colleagues no doubt
no doubt
that early on we had a problem I have
publicly said that we had a problem
early on there was a problem that had to
be corrected and it was corrected it was
a problem that was a technical problem
from within that was corrected and it
was an issue of embracing the way we
have now and should have the private
sector who clearly has the capability of
making and providing tests at the level
that we will need them for any of the
things that I've just spoken about so
having said that right now I totally
understand and I'm not alone my
colleagues understand that although we
say there are X number of tests out
there and you're gonna hear from at
brildor ah about that the fact is there
have been and still are situations that
are correctable and will be corrected so
isotopes gone because there
they're actually being more realistic
about not everything is perfect a lot
with my colleagues because believe it or
not some long time ago I was where they
are in the hospitals in the emergency
room looking at very sick individuals
that you need to take care of and I know
what it means when someone tells you hey
you have what you need and you look
around and you say well maybe you think
I have what I need but I don't really
have what I need
so we have to figure out how do we close
that gap and there are a lot of things
that I think we've learned and that we
are correcting and going to correct
namely you have a situation where tests
are needed and appropriate and either
people have found there's no tests or
there's no reagents or there's no swabs
or a person needed a test and we're told
that there was a restriction they
couldn't get a test these are all the
things that I'm telling you you already
know because you've heard them so right
now or there's a delay of five to seven
days and what does that mean if you want
to do if you want to get somebody at a
circulation we understand that that
existed but upon careful examination
what you are going to hear that many of
those have been already corrected and
other of those will be corrected because
what I think people don't appreciate
through no fault of their own is that
this is that there are two issues
there's supply and demand and if you
have a supply that can meet the demand
but the supply is not connected to
demand then supply demand falls apart
what do I mean by that I mean there is
existing capacity that we have that for
one reason or other maybe has not been
fully communicated as to the
availability of that existing capacity
and you're gonna hear about that now
there's production capacity that gets
better and better and better and that's
what we're talking about because for
what we need
we believe that with better
communications we'll be able to make
that happen
so I know there's gonna be a lot of
questions about that I didn't want to go
on too long but let me just finish by
saying given what I just said and what I
believe what you're going to hear that
for what we need in the first phase if
these things are done correctly what I
believe they can we will have and there
will be enough tests to allow us to take
this country safely through phase one
thank you okay more realistic I would
love to have seen numbers but maybe
someday we'll get that information Thank
You mr. vice president I want to make a
few comments here first I want to talk a
little bit about CDC has developed
multiple systems to monitor disease
outbreaks I think many of you are
familiar for example how we monitor for
foodborne illness or how we monitor for
antibiotic resistance in hospitals
well we've also developed a system to
monitor for upper respiratory tract
disease I can get the first slide there
this is an example because when we talk
about what we know about this current
pandemic the reality is we know a lot
because we've developed these monitoring
systems up on the slide is a system that
we've developed initially for flu and
what it does as you can see there's a
multiple different flu seasons and they
track them over the course of a year I
want you to look at the red line and
that happens to be this year's
respiratory season and you see there's a
peak there up over the 50 52-week and
that peak was when we actually had a
peak of influenza B this year was a
little different because after that
viral syndrome came down and you can see
it that actually we had another peak and
that's when influenza A was active
through our country and you can see
influenza A started to drop but then you
saw a third peak
that peak was you were looking at the
coronavirus 19 so we have systems all
the way down to the county level that we
can see where there's respiratory tract
illness and so it's not just just taking
a test it's monitoring these systems
that have been developed over the last
over decades and we have multiple ones
we have another one this that is
monitored in emergency rooms looking at
syndrome diagnosis and they show the
same thing so we're well equipped to
monitor to see when respiratory tract
viral disease will come and becomes a
very good surrogate for when you can
begin to understand that we need to
start looking more ideologically about
what's going on you can see now in week
15 we're really coming down to the
baseline background in terms of our flu
surveillance system from the overall
coronavirus situation right now the
second thing I wanted to say is that CDC
continues to enhance the state's Public
Health capacity to accelerate their
ability as Tony talked about it's
critical as we open America again to
diagnose individuals that present with
influenza like illness or corona virus
like illness to diagnose them to be able
to isolate them and to be able to
contact trace around them and then
diagnose the contacts and those that are
corona virus positive to go back and do
their contacts this is the traditional
public health approach which was started
in this outbreak in in January in
February and was quite successful when
as I mentioned before through February
27th this country only had 14 cases we
did that isolation and that contact
tracing and it was very successful but
then when the virus works
got beyond the public health capacity
but right now CDC is enhancing that
public health capacity and if I can get
the second slide I want to show you that
this is just showing as we sit here
today that CDC has embedded in these
health departments in all of these state
states across this country more than 500
individuals South Dakota also have an
additional almost hundred individuals
that are working on more than 20
coronavirus outbreaks that are going
through all these states and and finally
at the direction of the president we've
been asked to further enhance this
deployment in each of the states as the
vice president said so that there's
additional public health personnel to
help accelerate the state's ability to
basically move forward aggressively and
we assist them so they can
operationalize the president's
guidelines to open up America again so I
just wanted to make those points for
either today thank you dr. Burks all
right now we're gonna get you a present
and thank you dr. Falchi and dr.
Redfield for all of that clarity if we
can have the next slide and I'm gonna go
back to what dr. Falchi was talking
about just to emphasize those points
about the two types of tests and I'm
gonna talk about a third one so first we
all know about sampling in the front of
your nose to all of the labs out there
and to the providers you don't have to
use the nasal pharyngeal swab anymore
you can do front of nose sampling and
again as dr. Falchi talked about is that
as sampling for the virus itself that
replicates in your nose and as we know
throughout some of the respiratory
tissues RNA test the second test is a
course then your immune response to that
infection that's in your nose and so
that's the antibody test so those are
the two tests we want to talk about but
I want to come back to something that
both dr. Fauci and dr. Redfield said and
we covered yesterday testing is a part
of the exquisite monitoring that needs
to occur
in partnership with CDC and state and
local governments utilizing the
surveillance systems that are available
what we just talked about the flu
surveillance system because we no longer
have flu and the syndromic respiratory
system that is across the United States
and you can see it's going back to
baseline so that we'll be able to see at
the community level any deviation from
that baseline in addition what we talked
about yesterday was adding that
asymptomatic component because I think
you'll see as more and more articles
come out for surveillance that other and
monitoring that other states have done
higher and higher antibody in multiple
individuals who don't remember having a
sickness and that will give us an idea
that's our asymptomatic monitoring in
these sentinel monitoring sites and what
did we talk about yesterday we talked
about nursing homes we talked about
indigenous people and we talked about
vulnerable people in the inner city
really ensuring they decide that these
they're a little bit sort of you know
they can't say everything because they
don't want to get fired it's so much
better when Trump's not there and we
just hear from doctors adding and so
those are the two tests that we have one
available now two that have been
approved or three by the FDA I want to
just leave you with my last concept on
the antibody tests antibody tests have
different specificity and sensitivities
the FDA we've made that they're FDA has
been very cautious about the antibody
test because I heat see I know you see
reports every day of countries that have
ordered the antibody test and found that
they were 50 60 70 percent faulty so
we're taking that very seriously because
you never want to tell someone that they
have an antibody and potential immunity
when they don't and so those tests
perform better when there's a high
prevalence or high incidence of disease
so we want to work with mayor's around
the United States as those antibody
tests become available
to really see what it is in first
responders and health care workers in
the highest prevalence states so that we
can know about the quality and the real
life real field experience of those
assays because things can look very good
in the lab and then when you take them
into the field sometimes they're not as
good I've learned this lesson repeatedly
in working around the globe the next
slide so this is what we have asked
commercial and diagnostic companies to
be working on because when you talk
about multi millions worth of tests the
way we do this in the United States
today for strep flu in further influenza
and for malaria is we test for the
antigen now we don't know right now is
bution an antigen in the front of your
nose and so that is the question that
scientists and and companies are working
on right now because that becomes a
simpler test now the flu test I think
many of you will look it up tonight you
will see that outside of the flu season
because of the specificity of the test
it doesn't work so well so these are
tests we're working on today that would
be get like a screening test because if
you're positive on it it's a good test
but it may miss that you actually have
the flu so then you would move into that
what we call the nucleic acid test so
we're trying to build an algorithm of
tests that bring the full talent of the
science of the United States into the
reality of the clinic and so so what I'm
hearing is we have neither the quantity
nor the quality of the tests we need to
start letting it rip anywhere I promised
on both the senators and the governors
this is the United States current
platform capacity designated as high and
low throughput and what do I mean by
that there's we've talked about the high
throughput platforms of Roche and Abbott
and others and then we've talked about
the gene expert and other machines that
may be moderate to lower throughput I
want you to see how it's distributed
through the United States
so these are the current testing
platforms available today throughout the
United States for kovat 19 and as you
heard from dr. Falchi everything has to
be working from the swab to the
transport media to the laboratory to
really get those tests run and the
results back to the client
the next slide so then we've looked into
all of the testing capacity from those
platforms and this gives you an idea of
what that capacity is the darkest red
the you can see like in Texas and New
York those are in those are states that
have lots of different platforms as you
saw on the prior slide and the ability
if you just add up the platforms and the
potential for tests of over a million
tests per month and so this is what
we're working with each of those states
seems time per capita is extra relevant
right I mean doing that well we're
caught we're calling on the American
Society of microbiologists they have
they work closely with 300 lab directors
around the state around I just read a
book about how to lie with maps and this
is one of the things you really the raw
numbers are not actually useful here to
us for the military 35 years ago I've
called them back into service and
they're are calling lab by lab to find
out what are the technical difficulties
to bring up all the platforms that exist
in your lab is it swathes is it
transport media is it extraction and I
just really want to thank them they've
already worked through over 70 plus of
those laboratories to really understand
and the American Society of
microbiologists and the academic
societies of the laboratories are
working together to ensure that all of
this potential can be unlocked next
slide please
we talked a little bit yesterday about
New Orleans and we and the president
talked about how many tests New Orleans
has done during its outbreak which you
can see now is waning they've done
throughout the last month 27 tests per
thousand New Orleans and Louisiana ins
so 27 per thousand so that is a good
mark and that's what Italy has done
about 24,000 so in evaluating an
outbreak and really to get control of
this outbreak they did about 27 tests
for thousands so using that as a measure
next slide we then looked at cross all
the states of the United States of
America and looked for states that had
30 or more ability to do 30 or more
tests per thousand of their inhabitants
in each state and you can see that
across the country except for or a gun
and Maine and I worked over so close to
five thank you all so those are the
three states that were working on
building capacity and so this is just to
give you a perspective of how seriously
we're taking the data tell you thirty
per thousand per month is really not
that good we know exactly where they are
by geography by address by zip code what
their capacity is what their cumulative
capacity is what their roadblocks are on
non ability to run all their for one
point per day and we're addressing those
because each one of those is different
and you have to address each of them one
by one with the governor's with the
state and local labs and with all of the
hospitals I have not come across one
laboratory or one laboratory director or
one society that doesn't want to
contribute to solving this issue of
testing and ensuring that this testing
is available for everyone there is a
strong just as all the Americans have
social distance in behind everyone we
don't often talk about the laboratories
will talk about the nurses and doctors
on the front line behind all of them are
the laboratory technicians and
laboratory directors who are coming in
every day and putting things together to
ensure that every single person that
needs to be diagnosed is diagnosed and
hopefully you can see from these labs I
mean these slides that really there is
pasady out there it is our job working
with the states and having the state in
the leadership role in the laboratory
directors in the leadership role to
provide support to ensure that all the
potential for testing in the United
States is brought to bear I just want to
end with these are nucleic acid tests
there will never be the ability on a
nucleic acid test to do 300 million
tests a day or to test everybody before
they go to work or to 22-minute there
might be with the antigen test and so
that's why there's a role for nucleic
acid test there's a role for antibody
test and there's a role for the future
development of these other key tests the
full ability to the United States and so
when we finish this we'll be talking to
all Americans because there's other
tests that other Americans should have
and I think this is really brought to
light the importance of diagnosis and
we'll talk to you further about
hepatitis C and TB and other things that
we can do to sure every American is
healthy because I think this is really
raised the awareness among all Americans
about how you do tests for different
kinds in different parts of your disease
state and what is long-lasting immunity
and what may be long-lasting immunity
and what is a nucleic acid test and what
an antigen test is and with that Admiral
Gerard I just ordered an at-home vitamin
D and Biden vitamin b12 test for myself
I'll be taking it next week hoping to
score high marks approach and the
efforts we've put it away governors
across the country have been working
very closely with us to roll out the
level of testing that we have today and
all the information we presented to you
is going to be reviewed in the days
ahead with all of our governor's our
objective is to connect every one of
America's governors and state health
officials and to all of the labs that
are currently able to do a corona virus
and but as as as dr. Burke's doctor
pouchy both described we believe today
that we have the capacity in the United
States to a sufficient amount of testing
four states to move into phase one at
the time and manner that they deemed to
be appropriate with that I'll allow
Admiral Kurata
complete our briefing on testing and we
expect the President to return yeah
where is from something weird does seem
to be going on with Trump president and
thank you to all my really great
colleagues if Gerrard goes long it might
because they're signaling him to just
keep talking cuz Trump's and I'm ia art
by where we are today and just to visit
where we've come in such a short period
of time as everyone on the stage has
said before our testing right now is
well over three point seven eight
million tests that have been completed
and if you are impressed by bar graphs
that's over 1.2 million tests reported
just in the last week they should just
do a line ambassador burden talk to me a
little earlier and she said you know we
only do about two million molecular
tests a year for HIV something that's
been done for developed for 35 years
we're now doing twice that number of
tests in a month for a disease that has
never been known before that there's
never been a test developed before and
that's sort of where we are and where we
ramped up I also want to give you a
little idea the lighter blue or lighter
gray is is our our ID now tests so we
talked about the course if you show
cumulative over time it'll go up the
point is tests per day minutes and they
have a very specific role but they're
not for everybody if you've got a screen
a few thousand people for tests an hour
doesn't get you there on a machine you
have to use some of the larger higher
throughput items but they have a very
important role and again coming into the
market at 50,000 per day is really an
important adjunct to us um she talked
about the gene expert from Sofia very
important we don't talk about that very
much but it is one of the backbone
mobile point of care not as easy to do
per se as the Abbott but it is a point
of care test that really carries
tuberculosis screening all through
Africa
there are these machines you saw that on
her slide every one of the 50 states has
this in over 600 sites and they've done
over 700 thousand tests just on that
relatively low throughput but very
important platform next slide please
I wanted to give you an idea sort of how
the tests are distributed and how
they're changing over time on the left
are the state public health laboratories
and although their numbers are
relatively small about 350,000 the state
public health laboratories are
absolutely critical they're they're an
absolutely critical core component of
our testing not only were they there
early in first but they also do things
like support outbreak investigations and
nursing homes or investigations in
certain plants that have a close
proximity with everyone because of their
work environments they also do testing
on many people who do not have the
opportunity to be tested elsewhere and
they are performing outstandingly well a
CLA I know we hate acronyms but the
American Clinical Laboratory Association
this is America's commercial industrial
backbone that were standing behind the
President the Vice President and and
when I was there a few weeks ago in the
Rose Garden this is the lab core the
quest the bio reference laboratory Mayo
sonic in a RUP and you'll see they've
done almost 2.3 million tests this is
the very large high throughput machines
that dr. Burks talks about and and I
want to be clear about about this group
is that it doesn't matter where you are
I just took one of the largest labs and
I said map out for me where you are
with with it within 10 miles of where
you are every site in the country and
when you do that within 10 miles of a
site of one of these 93 percent of the
US population is covered these are truly
national reference labs that cover
almost everybody within the United
States so if you cannot get a test at
your hospital the chances are
overwhelming that you could send this to
the
labs that are fully caught up now they
have no backlog of tests they've ramped
up their production so their turnaround
time is about 48 hours because you may
need to transport it from the middle of
America out to a lab and result that but
that's really very very very good the
American Hospital Association also
academic labs as the vice president and
the president have said as more and more
labs come online they are increasing the
amount of testing that are done just at
the hospitals or at academic academic
medical centers now almost at 600,000
tests and again matching the other slide
I had the avid point of care test just
to give you a distribution and that
point of care test is being used very
importantly in very selective
populations where a point of care test
is really needed that could be in some
hospitals where someone needs to know
exactly if a person is positive or not
to go on a clinical trial or in a
nursing home investigation or sometimes
to get people screen to go back into the
work environment most people don't need
a point-of-care test in fact a
point-of-care test does not cannot
replace the millions of tests that are
here on the other side next slide I
don't know how interested you are in
swabs I did not know a whole lot of
swabs before a few weeks ago but there's
two points I want to make with with
these slides is yes there have been
constraining elements and they're
constrained for a couple reasons number
one because this is an unprecedented
scale up of this type of very I think we
can now say for sure the reason Trump
bailed is number one they're saying
things that admit not everything has
been perfect and number two this is just
too long and boring for Trump Trump
can't deal well he doesn't have the
attention span for this Italy and we
were stuck with that for a while because
it's not just the quantity it's the
quality what I don't want to do is put a
lot of things in the system to make
people believe that this is a good test
when it hasn't been validated by the FDA
to say that a positive is a positive and
a negative is a negative
but over the past weeks both the
scientific community the Gates
Foundation academic Medical
the FDA have really opened up our
ability to not stick that all the way
back in your nasopharynx but do the
anterior nose and to greatly broaden the
amount of swab types that are available
so we are really at a point right now
that over the neck by the end of April
we'll put another five million swabs in
addition to everything that's out there
now and by the end of May over 12
million new swabs in the system more
than enough to obtain the capacity that
we need yes for these molecular tests
you take a swab and you stick it in a
test tube and that task tube has to have
a specific kind of liquid in it and when
we started it was a viral transport
media a very special kind of media the
cdc has to make your own recipe if
you're interested in cooking you could
probably do that but it has a lot of
ingredients that go in there but still
very limiting we've worked with many
many different laboratories we've worked
with the FDA so now PBS phosphate
buffered saline a kind of just
laboratory grade salt water can be used
for this this greatly opens the ability
to expand the test to support all the
capability that dr. Burks talks about
and again by the end of April we will
have put well over five million new
tubes of either viral transport media or
saline into the system I am going to get
to a conclusion here but this was going
to be more of a technical briefing next
slide so let's talk about the fact that
the science tells us that we have and
will continue to have enough tests to
safely go into Phase one so let me be
very granular about this we've already
heard that it is beyond the possibility
to test everyone in this country every
day it's just it's not possible but it's
also a bad strategy because testing a
person now just means they're negative
now doctor foul Chi could be positive
tomorrow because it's brewing in his
system right now and we don't know it or
that he contacts
that's not the way we go about things
the way we go about things as dr.
Redfield said just this think of the
weather radar okay if the weather radar
is clear you're not gonna have a
thunderstorm or tornado when something
pops up that's when you've got to go to
where the action is or know that your
warning system is up so sort of think of
that in the background and I'll go
specifically about that
so that's monitoring let me talk about
how much testing we need just for
overall testing yes I'm just gonna give
you a number I'm not saying that this is
the number that's there but lets us take
a number that we are going to enter
phase one when there are two hundred
thousand new cases per month in the
United States don't get hung up on that
it's going to be much less than that but
let's just say two hundred thousand
cases so how many tests do we need
well we already illogical because the
states are deciding at the state level
not based on national case numbers this
is crazy guys now what's a safe number
over that you know if everybody I test
has the disease I'm not testing enough
right but if I test a hundred people to
have one person with the disease that's
probably over testing so we kind of
assumed that a safe number that really
gives us a good idea is if about one out
of ten people are positive then we know
we're over sampling in the population
enough that we're getting all the
positives so if there's 200,000 cases I
need about two million tests okay now to
go to dr. red Phil's point each one of
those that are positive have contacts
that need to be traced in on average the
CDC tells me that for every positive
there are about five contacts that
really need to be traced so let's assume
that those 200,000 people have five
contacts so now we have an extra million
test so two million tests out there to
detect the 200,000 cases an extra
million out there to trace those
contacts so we're up to about three
million cases if you want to put a fudge
factor say that's four million tests
okay those are generally done at the
main hospital labs the commercial labs
state and regional labs all this some of
you may notice that we're already close
to four million tests a day if we're
testing a month if we're testing one
hundred
50 K a day so it this is nuts the second
group of testing fits exactly perfectly
with the influenza-like surveillance
system that dr. Redfield talked about
this is the monitoring this is sort of
the radar the weather radar that it
would be out there that we're not
testing people who are symptomatic we
want to do testing on people who are
asymptomatic because you can have a
symptomatic carriage yacht you know you
can you could have this virus and shed
it and not have symptoms or only mild
symptoms so what is the strategy here
the strategy here this is an
unprecedented strategy okay this is this
is really unprecedented but we're going
to do between three and five hundred
thousand tests per week in the most
vulnerable populations that we know that
the virus could circulate it's not
another what are they number one nursing
home and long-term care facilities we
know that from the history of this of
this virus that that can circulate and
be devastating and it could circulate
even in a way that you don't have
symptoms so we're gonna survey in a very
controlled way driven by the CDC
supervised by the CDC surveys over it we
may not get to everyone but surveying in
the areas to cover in a selective way
the fifteen thousand or so nursing homes
secondly we want to work in vulnerable
members in cities and this is the way we
think about that is community health
centers I'm a huge fan of community
health centers that are led by hersa
there are there are about thirty
thousand community health center sites
they take care of 30 million people
children adults elderly they care for
about one-third of Americans below the
poverty level
they are arrayed to take care of our
most vulnerable populations so we want
to survey on asymptomatic people in
those community health centers we also
want to do in some of our indigenous
population and you know very early I was
out here bringing machines to the Indian
Health Service and in fact guys clearly
stalling because Trump's
amia right provide care to the Indian
Health Service and their director and
chief medical officer are both Admirals
in the Indian Health Service Plus work
fete workplace monitoring particularly
for workplace environments that may have
very close contact or may have a high
risk and some of those could be
agricultural facilities so let's us
total that out we have 200,000 people
who need a diagnosis to make that
diagnosis we want to test 2 million okay
so that's 2 million we're going to
contact trace with a million and let's
just throw you a fudge factor of about
25 percent on that so that's 4 million
and we have this background testing of
about 400 of about 400,000 per month so
to say 4 he said that the 400,000 was
per week at the long-term care centers
million you followed my number so I want
you to understand per month that's one
pardon me for phase one right for phase
one and I want to tell you that's really
how it adds up and that's where we are
right now we're doing about 1 1 million
to 1.2 million per week we are going to
continue to push that farther and
further as he's switching between
testing periods he's imagining that all
this starts when we only have 200
thousand new cases per month which is
very far away very far away I'll ask the
team to step back up for questions and
comes missing we do anticipate these
scheduled permitted that the president
be returning momentarily
please will there be enough testing for
phase 2 do you have to wrap up capacity
rad
how do you deal with that's a fantasy
right now phase two is a fantasy right
now yeah that's a great question and at
what we will be doing is monitoring how
much we have to use in Phase one to
really help inform phase two because it
what they're really unknown in this to
be completely transparent is a
symptomatic and asymptomatic spread and
so if we find that there's a lot of
asymptomatic individuals that we find in
this active monitoring in what we can
see are very much concerned about the
most vulnerable then we will have to
have increased testing to cover all of
those all of those sites and as we've
made clear to the governor's and other
health officials we're going to continue
to scale the testing as the president's
made clear we want we want governors and
states to manage the testing operations
in their states we've given we've given
criteria we've given guidance for how we
think that would best operate but we're
looking for the states we're looking for
the governor's to manage it but in the
midst of that all these great experts
working with all these great facilities
are going to continue to use that great
American ingenuity to scale and increase
the availability of testing for states
to be able to implement as they move
closer and closer to that that day the
president speaks of often where we
reopen America and put all of America
back to work earlier today saint Inslee
said that your tweets encouraging
separations hey Inslee said your tweets
encouraging liberation at Michigan
Minnesota of Virginia where foam in st.
rebellion wondering how that squares
with
the sober and methodical guidance that
you issued yesterday well I think we do
have a so green guidance but I think
some things are too tough and if you
look at some of the states you just
mentioned it it's too tough not only
relative to this income here what
they've done in Virginia with respect to
the second amendment it's just a
horrible thing they did a horrible thing
the governor and he's the governor under
a cloud to start off with so when you
see what he said about the second
Amendment when you see what other states
have done no I think I feel very
comfortable good I think just to be
clear when you talk about these states
on Michigan Minnesota Virginia do you
think that they should live there stay
at home orders or can you talk so no but
I think elements of what they've done is
what is liberation it's just too much
you know the elements because I've
already said but certainly a second
Amendment and second amendment having to
do with the state of Virginia what
they've done in Virginia is just
incredible
ok please sir are you concerned though
that people coming out in protest are
going to spread kovat to other people
they're congregating in ways that health
experts have said they should not know
these are people expressing their views
I see where they are and I see the way
they were wooden they seem to be very
responsible person idiot but it's you
know they've been treated a little bit
rough president I'm curious about some
more of the dynamics we might
yes the country begins reopening as you
feel kind of like a puzzle so as you've
mentioned we have states that we're
already seeing their curves begin to
flatten but then there are others like
Florida or more rural parts of the
country where they are projected to peak
for weeks or even months so can you talk
a little bit about some of the
difficulties that those later peaking
States might face that they need to stay
locked down so longer even as other
places around them are starting to open
back up well we're seeing great numbers
in almost every state with simply laps
we're really saying you know the beds
the numbers we have to look at are the
beds the beds being occupied very good
which is essentially people going in
that means that you have fewer people
that are sick fewer people that feel
they have to go to a hospital and those
numbers are dropping really
precipitously so I think that we're just
seeing a lot of good signs now a place
like New York New Jersey and certain
parts of Louisiana Louisiana has been
incredible lately would you look at that
drop that drop has really been great
Michigan's had a hard time but it's it's
starting to do well so I just think
Illinois is another one you know you
look at some of the numbers but everyone
is is dropping and they're dropping
rather quickly we don't have any hotspot
that's developed where all of a sudden
you say well other than we did have a
rethinking literal lie to we're
incredibly we have Arkansas and and
these states are growing by 60 to 200
percent a day these are dangerous lies
who owned that company there's a weird
situation but generally speaking it's
been very good the numbers have been
really improving greatly please do the
best mr. president
US intelligence is saying this
that the coronavirus likely came from a
level 4 lab in Wuhan untruth there's
also another report that the NIH under
the Obama administration in 2015
gave that lab three million dollars in a
grant why would the you ask a grant like
that to China the Obama administration
gave them a grant of 3.7 million I've
been hearing about that and we've
instructed that if any grants are going
to that area were looking at it
literally about all we know right now is
that a couple years ago there was
concern expressed about a lab in Wuhan
there's not any actual evidence that
this virus came from there and it's very
irresponsible based on what's known
right now to spread that take a look but
I understand it was a number of years
ago was the grant was May 2015 2015 who
was president then I wonder no
negotiations are under way for the next
round of funding for small business to
know if tens of billions of dollars went
in a matter of days the first time well
this next what we've package be enough
well I think it will certainly it's
gonna get us to a point that's going to
be rather beautiful we think that that
will be the point and it could be they
want more but maybe at a certain point
we're going to stop it's been a
tremendous success it's been executed
flawlessly SBA's done a very good job
but the banks have done a great job
whether it's Bank of America Wells Fargo
the the community banks have been
incredible I think we had over 4,000
community banks a lot of people didn't
know you had that many banks but 4,000
community banks they gave the money out
it's so organized and it's been such a
great program and so essentially we're
waiting for 250 billion dollars the
Democrats are refusing to do it this is
money that essentially is going to the
workers it's going to keep these
companies whole restaurants and a lot of
great companies and it's a small amount
of money relative to what it represents
because it represents small businesses
it represents them staying in business
and you know when you look at it people
don't know small businesses represent
approximately 50% of the
our of our nobody business enterprises
not all the big monster businesses that
you read about every day it's all of
these small businesses when added it's
something that should be approved by the
Democrats the Republicans wanted badly
and the people wanted very badly follow
up on that nearly 10% of the loans that
were given out were for five million
dollars but some small business owners
say they can't even get a loan for a
hundred thousand dollars is that what
they would no they would get that but
they have to approve an Adu nobody knew
it was gonna be this Chris Steakhouse
got 20 mil it's been a tremendous
success as a program people are they
really want it and some people won't be
able to get there keep their business
open unless they get that money it's
been a tremendous success it's been
executed flawlessly it's been I mean
with few exceptions it's really been
good and I think the Democrats are gonna
do it look Nancy Pelosi she's away on a
vacation or something and she should
come back she should come back and get
this done yeah otherwise i deceptive
just members of the House and Senate are
in in their home districts vacation well
hospitals are a good thing hospitals
have been decimated by this you know
they've given up their business which is
good because they did the right thing in
order to take care of the kovat 19 and
no hospitals I'm with that all the way
they want to add to hospitals we could
also add it into phase four if we do a
phase four phase 4 would be hopefully
infrastructure a lot of people are
talking about the best thing we could do
for this country would be the payroll
tax cut that I've been suggested
suggesting a lot of Democrats like it
believe it or not the payroll tax cut
and art Laffer whose tremendous he's at
tremendous in fact he recently got the
Presidential Medal of Freedom it like he
got at the back to five years old but I
think you might be a little bit older
than that he looks so great but art
Laffer said the single best thing you
can do is the payroll tax cut and I
would just about agree with that and I'd
like to see that I'm not sure that we're
gonna get that
I think that's something that could be
done it's simple it's really good for
both the company that employs these
people and for the people that are
employed so we're gonna see whether that
happens or not the pay ROI put it out
there the payroll tax cut would be a
tremendous incentive for this country
staged in China now says it's Kelowna
buyers death poll in Wuhan is 50% higher
up to about 4,000 does that sound like a
credible number to you well you know
when I listen to the press every night
saying we have the most we don't have
the most in the world deaths the most in
the world has to be China
it's a massive country it's gone through
a tremendous problem with us a
tremendous problem and they must have
the most so today I saw they announced
that essentially they're doubling up on
the numbers and that's only in Wuhan
they're not talking about outside so it
was up 50% but Trump thinks that's
doubling it is what it is safe it is
what it is what I said what a sad state
of affairs investigation into whether
the virus escaped from this lab and move
on how active is that and we're looking
at it a lot of people are looking at it
it seems to make sense they talk about a
certain kind of bat but that bat wasn't
in that area if you can believe this
that's what they're down to now is bats
but that bat is not in that area that
bat wasn't sold at that wet zone it
wasn't salt there that bat is 40 miles
away so a lot of strange things are
happening but there is a lot of
investigation going on and we're gonna
find out all I can say is wherever it
came from came from China in whatever
form 184 countries now are suffering
because of it and it's too bad isn't it
and it could have been solved or easily
when it was just starting it could have
been solved really very easily
yeah thank you sir so about the 80
million payments that have gone out
imagine you said that less than 1% have
had snafus but that could be 800,000
snafus so we've also seen what I was
saying it's less than 1% and the snap
was a very minor no they were they were
eighteen eighty million payments went
out over a period of a few days and they
caught certain mistakes that they made
but this is a tiny amount of mistakes I
can tell you a mistakes were made in
government we're wrong countries were
signed okay
80 million this has been a tremendous
success and any mistake that was made
they've been caught and it's less than
1% that's a very good percentage I can
tell you for government I mean how about
how about the Obama website the Obama
care website where they spend 5 billion
dollars on building a website that you
could have built for for peanuts okay
[Music]
anything that was sent at site sometimes
you send a check to somebody wrong
sometimes people are listed they die and
they get a check that can happen you're
talking about I guess the number is
about 80 million people yeah sure we'll
get that back everything we're gonna get
back but it's a tiny amount they've done
a fantastic job this was done in a
matter of a few days so your campaign
said today that they are planning on
resuming rallies before the election is
there a timeline that you're looking at
would it be restricted to certain states
have you thought about how that would
work well I hope we can do rallies it's
great for the country it's great spirit
it's great for definitely now thinks
it's a that to me it's a tremendous way
of getting the word out if you look at
our success rate we've had tremendous
success we win where we have rallies
including endorsements of candidates or
sponsors I think unparalleled there's
nothing like it so I certainly hope we
can have rallies we'll find out I don't
like the rally is where we're sitting
like you're sitting I mean you got many
reporters outside trying to get into
this room and I come in I'm looking at
this room and I see all this it loses a
lot of flavor
it loses to me a lot of flavor but I
hope we're gonna have rallies I think
they're gonna be bigger than ever I will
say this the rallies that we're having
until we had a stop with regard to the
problem they're bigger than ever in the
next 3-4 months were screwed here than
they were I think even substantially
bigger we go into the biggest arena I've
turned away twenty thirty thousand
people sometimes in Chris Kurt you know
one case I think they said in New Jersey
we had a hundred and seventy five
thousand people show up for an arena
there holds nine thousand people I
questioned that and they showed up and
the reporters even reported that that
was almost shocking to me but I hope we
can resume rallies because I think
they're an important part of politics
these are soon enough Trump may kill off
voters before they even cast a ballot
phase one was to not reopen until Phase
two many parents don't have an option to
work from home so how can you get
businesses back up and running as long
as schools are closed well I think the
businesses are going to and I think now
we've given the businesses a real jolt a
real positive jolt they were able to
keep their employees you know without
the employees if the employees leave
that area if they leave you know who
knows where they're going or if they get
another job maybe someplace else you're
not gonna have the same business so we
gave them money to hold their employees
they're going to do that we hope we can
do two hundred and fifty billion dollars
more it's it's absolutely so inexpensive
I know that represents and we hope
that's gonna happen but I think I really
think look you see it with a stock
market the market was up seven or eight
hundred points today and if you would
have told me that we would have a virus
the likes of which this world has not
seen since 1917 which was the Spanish
flu where anywhere from 75 to 100
million people were killed and then we'd
have a stock market that's not far below
its all-time high and it's starting to
get a little low you know then you had a
thousand point increase and a twelve
hundred point increase so now we have a
stock market that's at a point where
it's not very far away from where it was
and we've gone through it closed
literally a closed country remember this
also I mean we have had a closed economy
we had the best economy anywhere in the
world by far we're the best economy
we've ever had and remember this the
dollar is very strong and dollars strong
dollars are overall very good but it
does cause problem it's harder to sell
outside of the country etc it's just a
little harder for manufacturers
sometimes it's a lot harder everybody
wants to invest in our country everybody
wants and you know we're paying almost
zero in interest like in some cases zero
a lot of people don't know that we've
never had that before people want the
safety of our country but if you would
have told me that a market was where it
is today and today we had almost I guess
more than a seven hundred point increase
and we're at a point which is you know
that's not what it was but it's not that
far off I would have told you that's got
to be in a possible the reason that is
is because there is a great pent-up
demand this country is gonna come back
and it's gonna gonna come back so we
have to get rid of the virus we've got
to open up our country we're gonna open
it up in quadrants we're gonna open it
up as states remember the question was
about schools there and they should work
on their own borders and everything
because you don't want to have people
pouring through a border of a state that
isn't infected and you have people
coming but perhaps outside that's one of
the reasons I was asking Tony two days
ago about masks well why in Wyoming or
Montana what they have to wear masks
that numbers are very good the reason if
if somebody comes from outside you know
which is a very severe but maybe rare in
life again and it's gotta be up to them
it's a recommendation but we'll see but
if you would have told me how well we're
doing after we went through the worst
event of its kind since 1917 it's pretty
amazing questions alright guys I
apologize but that's gonna do it for me
I do have a prior commitment I actually
feel like this may be the most
propagandist one we've ever seen at
almost everything being said is literal
lies so I'm out certainly plenty of
places you can watch the rest but
otherwise we'll be back with you at the
start of next
week
you